you've been in Japan now for nearly a
year how have your uh thoughts changed
on everything over that year since
you've been here so are you still
enjoying it I love it oh my God what's
the main takeaways that you've kind of
felt over the past few months yeah like
how do you just things about Japan yeah
like what are some things you love more
worse yeah yeah some things you don't
like oh oh man where do I even start
first of all the food uh
so freaking good yeah not not had
tipping not being a thing oh my oh my
God oh my God
um
what are some like culture shock moments
for me
do you still experience it you think
like in everyday life or are you kind of
like pasta now after you I think I've
I'm pretty much like used to everything
it's just like recently the thing that
made me do like a double take is I'm not
used to seeing like little ass kids
walking by themselves at like the train
station yes that still shocks me I'll be
walking with Titus and it'll be like 8
p.m and we're walking home from the
train station I just see like a
six-year-old with this big ass backpack
walking past and we're like where are
your parents yeah we're your parents
like I feel like if I would have a kid
in Japan that would be the one thing
that would [__] terrify me yeah it's
scary it's being like Oh you're three
years old now off you go on to the train
with you yeah I did notice that they do
put a lot of trust into their kids here
just to get around by themselves yeah
but uh even just like even not even on
the train like just sometimes I'd be
walking back from like the office or
wherever I am and then there would just
be like a four-year-old walking home
from Like Preschool by themselves and
I'm like are you are you lost how do you
know your way back yeah how do you know
your way back I didn't I barely died
I could barely get around my own house
when I was four years yeah let alone
like the neighborhood you know so it's
like every time I see them I always
think like are you lost like are you
okay it's got to be a plant by the
police
you're trying kidnap a decoy [__]
they they're swapped Chris Hanson's just
like
come on kids actually commute yeah it's
because they want to get them into the
salary man life immediately they're like
I start commuting yeah get into it also
the kids are so cute I say that in like
the least weird way I possibly can just
like you know how like okay I feel like
I think it was weird and that you said
that it was fine it wasn't weird thank
you because like because I feel like in
America people like to dress their kids
to look like many adults a lot of the
times
I guess really do they yeah well like
they honestly I've never looked this was
Americans just wear [__] t-shirts
everywhere well they buy them like
noticed that a lot of parents buy their
kids like little miniature versions of
like what they wear so it's like I'll
match with Mommy
but like it just looks weird because
it's like that's a toddler and like a
supreme sweater what are you doing
but now I'm trying to remember what I
wore as a kid
uh my fashion is horrendous [__] my
parents would allow me to wear a hat
yeah I'm just wondering did my parents
dress me up like them no I don't think
they did you know you know what was one
of my favorite shows going off I'm sure
someone can uh can relate it was the
Flaming slasher shirt did you ever see
those oh actually you know I know every
kid in our generation like there was at
least one kid that was like black shirt
with like Flames coming from the bottom
yeah and the slasher logo I liked
wearing the school uniform because then
on weekends I was like [__]
you know what to wear you still like
that I remember I had a thought as a kid
I was like man I wish you'd wear my
school uniform every day so I don't
think I hated wearing my school uniform
I loved it because I was like great were
you just going and then and then because
you go home and you watch American TV
and they're all bullying each other for
not wearing certain clothes or looking
like a nerd it's like was that weird
yeah we don't have that problem yeah
because we're all West school uniforms
you don't have uniforms in America do
you most schools don't no no because
it's only like privates yeah only if
it's like private school or like
Catholic schools you don't have to worry
about [__]
it is nice but at the same time it's
like one less thing to get bullied about
a lot of other stuff yeah
I don't remember anyone ever getting I
don't think I've ever witnessed anyone
at my school getting bullied for like
what they were wearing yeah and why is
it such like a common Trope in like
American High School films
well I'm not basing it off that well I
mean I have seen that yeah yeah I just
assumed because kids are the worst kids
will do anything yeah yeah but kids
won't pick clothes they'll find your
deepest insecurities and they'll and
they'll they're evil our kids are evil
sometimes no chill not Japanese kids
though they're adorable as [__] oh until
they hit highs high school that's when
they become evil and then they learn
about bullying and they're like
they've got like their little like their
little yellow box
backpacks that are like twice their size
it's so cute have you ever have you ever
seen like when the teachers leading like
a group of school kids yeah they're so
[__] adorable it makes my day so much
better just seeing like this line of
like these these kids just and the
teacher at the front being like okay
let's go
like Nursery yeah
20 kids in this car and I think she'll
be dragging it around it's like oh
that's cute I think it is pretty
adorable to say no but what happened
earlier like last year when when ditus
and I just moved into our apartment uh
we we'd like
we weren't used to like saying hello to
like neighbors or like strangers yeah
but now it's like pretty normal there
was this little kid that walked past us
in like our apartment hallway thing
right
and as we weren't expecting him to say
anything but as we were walking by he
was like
and we're like oh it's too high and so
we're like oh okay like so we do gotta
say I don't know I thought maybe it'd be
weird if I just like said hi to like the
kids yeah so then later that same day we
saw another kid by our apartment complex
as we're walking back diet is looks at
me it's like oh konnichiwa and the kid's
like
so you gotta wait for the kids yeah yeah
yeah
my favorite one that that's really cute
as well but like I recently had one
where like I was coming back from uh
from somewhere and near my apartment
there was this kid that just like kept
staring at me while I was waiting for
the lights and I'm just like you good
kid you're good what's up and then I
crossed the road and as he was crossing
the road he runs past me and stops in
front of me and goes
all right you be careful yeah
where your parents
adorable so cute yeah
kids in Japan no matter what they do
like if they they or you know kids are
curious and sometimes they you know go
out their way to say hello and it's like
when they like ask you questions as well
then you just they're so cute that's
because they just just like if you ever
come to Japan and you uh you you will
know what we're talking about when you
see like a group of kids walking walking
along they're like like you said like a
group of ducklings yeah crossing the
road right even they it's just something
about the aesthetic you know I don't
know it's the Year little yellow hats
and the and like the backpacks it's a
Vibe aesthetic toddler core yeah
what the [__]